[Narrator] Hi class, this is homework assignment #6 on SLAM,
and we're going to practice some more questions about the graph SLAM algorithm,
and I will ask you something new about how to make graph SLAM more efficient
towards the end of this homework assignment.
There's 3 questions and 1 new thing,
which comes with additional questions and a programming assignment.
Let's dive in.
In this example, picture a robot that starts at initial position 5.
This robot which lives in 1D, even though I'm drawing this in 2D,
sees a landmark with a relative measurement of 2.
It then moves to coordinate X1 by taking a step of 7.
It now sees a different landmark, L1, with a measurement value of 4.
Finally, it moves again with a motion 2,
and now it sees the same second landmark, not the original one,at a value of 2.
Obviously, when I work it out and solve this,
you find that the best coordinates over here are 12 and 14,
with landmark coordinates of 7 and 16,
but none of the numbers I just told you will be inserted in the question I'm about to ask.
Picture the matrix omega and the vector C.
I want you to add all these constraints into omega
with a caveat that for the initial constraint I assume the strength is just 1,
so enter it the way you're used to.
Now let's assume the motion update has a sigma of 1,
but the measurement update--the sigma for measurements has a value of 0.5,
and remember we weigh those updates with 1 over sigma,
which in the measurement case would therefore be 2.
I want you to fill in the values for sigma and for C for this specific example.
I gave you some of the sigma values and some of the C values,
and I want you to fill in the missing values over here.
You can check whether you got them correct by verifying that I got those numbers correct,
and you can also solve for omega minus 1 times C,
and out should come the right positions shown in the diagram over here.